[Music]
so we want Kitty hostel be the dog vacay
for cats but as you can guess it's a big
problem that needs big resources hey
[Music]
you'll be in here today this is nice
this is where you do data entry no this
is weird but I don't actually need you
to do anything ok awesome
kiddy hostels out of runway
I'm sorry runway it's a fancy way of
saying we're out of money there's a
group of investors coming at noon and if
they don't put in I'm gonna to lay off
pretty much everyone I need them to
think we're much bigger than we are so
just to be clear here you want me to do
nothing correct but you are gonna pay me
I'll pay you double not to mess this up
when I bring the investors around just
nod and smile no wants to talk to the
director of database engineering anyway
sorry director of database engineering
night-night I don't cool with you oh
yeah it's fine
don't know that anyone else was
available at a moment's notice who could
take this seriously
there's a lot on the line yeah yeah I
think I do well you can tell the
scottsdale office their numbers were
[ __ ] last quarter mm-hmm yeah that's a
Taylor Swift song whose dog is this
you must be Brandon's sister not today
sorry that's less elaborate character
you must be our fearless vision oh sorry
no no no I like it
this'll work
why did you see the right things I will
live breathe and sleep this company I'll
stop at nothing until we're leaders in
whatever market is again it you're a
killer
I'm your killer now what's my title you
seem like a VP of customer acquisitions
I love it
I'll acquire the [ __ ] out of fake
customers for you that's the fire we
need you'll take Brandon's office excuse
me it just makes
investors will be here in an hour
Brandon make sure she knows the drill
shoot I would have to call David and
tell him I won't be home in time for
dinner who is David my husband
we met at Stanford Business School okay
this guy is gonna pay us double to sit
in a room and not cause any trouble not
to treat this like an audition for the
social network - no Brandon you don't
get it this is a happening okay I know
this I'm the lead at a workplace sitcom
look I've gone through a lot of these
temp gigs already and this is the first
one that has any long-term potential I
mean this guy's paying me to do nothing
I could do this forever
we could do this forever no right now we
need to focus on inhabiting our
environment so he can become one with
the workplace no no no no no
inhabitation
that's gonna be your office there I'm
gonna find a cubicle try to ring this in
it so talk to your superior that way
Scottsdale back on the line how are you
[ __ ] hi hey figured you'd want
to see the latest server load reports I
I don't but the database is running out
of memory dude did Britney put you up to
this the new VP you're real sorry you're
a real employee here I'm part-time oh
never mind
um so the database is running out of
memory that sounds bad seems like
catching our most recent queries would
reduce the strain do we have to buy
anything for that to happen
no just takes a couple lines of code but
do you think there will be any issues
with backwards compatibility
compatibility sounds positive yeah I
think you should go for it okay I'm on
it
good job Thanks
hello
I have Britney calling for Brandon
Britney please hold for Britney the
investors are here shoot no there's no
Showtime
Britney that's Brandon he's our database
engineer once we reach critical mass in
Los Angeles San Francisco is next have
you found a scalable acquisition
strategy well depends on your definition
of scale how about we go into my office
for a brief presentation uh-huh
not now Britney maybe after we go over
the financials sounds good I'll sit in
follow me
actually ah sorry guys I have a meeting
with Britney now to discuss scaling the
database scale yes talk to me about
scale chase tells me he's got a saddle
on a unicorn that's really the [ __ ] gold
okay um our first step is to cash all
recent queries this doesn't cost
anything upfront but it should reduce a
lot of strain in the long run makes
sense
see build a world-class team Sarah the
database change you authorize to cause
the kernel panic you authorize the
database change yeah a couple lines of
code well you do know how to fix it
right yeah you made him the director of
database engineering you guys need a
moment no this will just take a second
I'm not paying you to think I'm paying
you not to [ __ ] up and you did royally
Hey look I don't need any input from a
lunatic [ __ ] either hey
now you're not gonna let him talk to an
executive of your stature that way now
are you Brittany
certainly not you just remember who pays
the bills around here
what yeah daddy didn't cut you a check
and put us on the board for you to [ __ ]
all over us
whoa trouble at the unicorn farm what
the hell are you talking about
I'm really sorry no I'm really sorry I
expected more from our portfolio
companies you invested daddy did yeah
that's right it's daddy's money that's
in those unicorn saddle pants yeah and
we have first-in-first-out shares which
I'm sure chase told you all about he did
not look I think we all have a lot to
think about so we'll be in touch do you
have a card I'd love to get together
talk shop
voila I do magic
fired no [ __ ] yeah you can't treat
people like wet garbage call the car
uh-huh yes would you bring the car
around please you know that was kind of
Awesome I know that's Dale your sales
team stack up yet hey what happened to
that dog don't worry about I stole it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]